Since black women are done,
rightfully so, I totally get it.
They're done educating, they're done teaching,
they're done helping any of us.
I feel it's somebody's gotta fucking do the part.
Their part. I'm not a white woman.
I know I look like one, I know I pass for one,
but I'm not a white woman.
So to the white women with this like,
blue bracelet idea, cause you want everybody in the world to know
you're not one of those white women.
You are still centering yourself.
You're still getting it wrong.
Just because you voted the.
The right way doesn't necessarily make you an ally or a friend
or make. Make sure that you're doing all the right things.
As a white woman who voted the right way.
You should, instead of being so concerned
with everybody knowing that you voted the right way.
So now you wanna wear a blue bracelet
cause you just don't wanna be blamed for this.
That's. You're missing the whole fucking point.
Now it's your job to step up and speak and.
And educate and talk to your friends
and get the women to leave their shitty husbands and to,
you know, do all the right things.
It's not just about showing your.
I didn't do. It wasn't my fault.
You're still centering yourself.
It wasn't my fault. I didn't do that.
I did the right thing. I'm one of the cool white women.
Cause don't you think the white women
Who did vote the wrong way
are gonna just get the same fucking blue bracelet
so they can be accepted like you.
It's not about the blue bracelet.
It's not about people knowing you voted what way you voted.
It's about doing what's right for the people around you.
So maybe give up on the fucking bracelet
and start using your voice a little bit more.